parents of a missing florida woman are
taking the investigation
into their own hands 24 year old
jennifer
kessey disappeared from her orlando
condo nearly 15 years ago
there have been no arrests or named
suspects
her parents sued the orlando police
department for a copy of their
daughter's case file
and reached a settlement last year now
with the files in hand
they hope to solve the case peter van
sant reports for this week's 48 hours
this phantom figure remains the most
important clue
in the disappearance of jennifer kessey
who vanished on january 24
2006. i think of her all the time
lauren mccarthy was jennifer's best
friend
the greatest friend i've ever had
two days after jennifer went missing her
car was found in an apartment complex
parking lot
about a mile away from where she lived
but there was no sign of jennifer
and no conclusive dna but this
surveillance video
showed a person parking her car at noon
on the day she disappeared
it was like being hit with a ton of
bricks the phantom figure then walked
away
in the direction of jennifer's complex
the person was so casual
something really bad obviously happened
and they were just
so casually dropping this car off like
they were
you know getting home from work but the
person could not be identified
because the surveillance video captured
a photo every three seconds
and each time the figure's face was
obstructed by a fence post
after years of having no solid leads now
it's our turn
in 2017 the kessies recruited private
investigator michael tereta
to help them conduct their own
investigation
toretta learned from speaking with
people who lived in jennifer's complex
that construction workers were living in
an empty apartment
just across from jennifer he believes
they were laying carpet
the day she disappeared so what i'm
thinking is jennifer comes out
and then is abducted
from those individuals across the way
she's locking the door and never sees it
coming he also learned that
10 months after jennifer disappeared a
person was seen dumping a rolled up
piece of carpet
into a lake not far from her condo but
last year when police searched the lake
no carpet was found
this is something that is haunting me we
need
to see what's inside that carpet
and peter van sant joins us now peter
good morning first
i can't imagine being the parent of a of
a daughter who disappeared 15 years ago
and having to conduct my own
investigation this amazing story have
police been able to identify any of the
construction workers who lived across
the way
not as yet when jennifer was living in
that building it was going through a
conversion from apartments to
condominiums many of the laborers were
day workers
and some may have been undocumented and
they
basically disappeared after jennifer
vanished and
part of this hope that we have is that
someone will come forward
with a name or names after they see this
report yeah and what about that
eerie phantom figure in the parking lot
uh any any possible identity even on
that person
we've had people which you'll hear in
the course of our report
who think well this could be this person
or that but as
of now that's been enhanced by nasa uh
it's been studied
uh incredibly they're not even quite
sure if it's male or female i see a man
in that picture
but again they're hoping that people
will recognize the person
the the figure the man i think it's a
man has a mullet in the back
thin walking across and he was walking
from the car
to the construction site so that's why
they think perhaps it's one of the
workers
uh that was uh doing the remodeling at
the condo complex
okay peter van sant thanks so much peter
you can see peter's report where